[EDDIE HARRIS, "FREEDOM JAZZ
DANCE"]
The overarching theme is social
equality, police brutality,
media, news
propaganda, the things
that we unfortunately
have to see,
it feels to me as a Black
man day in and day out.
It really weighs
on me and bugs me
that I have to keep
addressing the same thing.
People think, oh, you're
living your dreams,
traveling the world and stuff.
It's true.
But I really would like to just
write love poems if I could.
But the reality is,
like Nina Simone said,
you have the artist's duty
is to reflect the times.
I've watched war commence
on colored kids who
wither like acres of
daffodils anchored in bodies
of bloody water where
the deceased are greeted
with the deep indifference.
I've witnessed temperamental
white teams being
tamed with tasers but Black
babies with empty hands
oftentimes pacified
with gunfire.
[BEATBOXING]
I've even seen people pull their
phones from pockets and purses
like pistols to shoot
indisputable proof.
But Facebook footage is never a
footprint for indictment here.
The reality is hands
up or not, gunshots
turn our torsos into hashtags.
Therefore, we reformat
tribute tweets
in an attempt to
retract that trauma.
But that trick is
never a treatment
for our trail of
tears, especially when,
especially when,
especially when--
I do feel like we're
making progress.
But we have a long ways to go.
So if something I'm
saying strikes a chord
or resonates with a
student, just one,
I feel like my job is done.
Because that student
can go on to change
the course of the world.
[JET LEWIS, "UNLEARNING HOW TO
SAVE THE PLANET"]
It's hard to break
into this field
when the first thing everyone
notices about you is your race.
Look at my face.
Why can't I also
inhabit this space?
There's diversity in
the birds and the trees.
But we have not figured out how
to guarantee the same diversity
in the kinds of people
that want to protect them.
We are all looking to do sort of
this broad-reaching conception
of thought through sound to
be able to reach the listener
and help conjure up images
of the difficulty of living
in this time period,
but also the hope that's
coupled with it, in order to
gain a deeper understanding
and empathy.
These words, and the music,
and all of these things
that we're dealing
with are just a means
of trying to
communicate a better
way of being with one another.
[SEAN JONES, "PANGEA"]
The harmonies of all
things resonating as one.
[TERRI LYNE CARRINGTON,
"SEEN/UNSEEN--
EXPLORATIONS, INTERROGATIONS,
AND RESILIENCE"]
[VOCALIZATIONS]
The piece centers around the
resilience of Black women
to imagine what it's like
being born as a Black woman
into a world that's
pretty unjust to you.
Just how we've had
to navigate through.
So many things and
really always emerge
still hopeful, and still
joyful, and all of the emotions,
and all of the things
that just go along
with a certain kind of struggle.
And it's always great to see
someone as vibrant as Fred.
His conducting style is unique.
It's very energetic.
He's moving.
He's sort of in the moment,
picking different pieces
of this and this.
And I think that
that's really important
to have someone that is rooted
in the traditions of conducting
while being so experimental.
[BEATBOXING]
The main thing is to be as
honest as possible musically
really.
Situations like this are
a really good opportunity
to, I think, step outside
of one's comfort zone,
especially when
collaborating with others
and being given an
opportunity to share
your sort of musical
voice and identity
in a way that adds to
someone else's vision.
[BRAXTON COOK, "LOST AND FOUND"]
Reimagining this
American-made playing field
built to kill my kind on sight.
But the way I see it, the way I
see it, we don't look the part
or fit the picturesque
European picture
frame the same as Mona Lisa.
See, our beauty be different.
Be curly, be kinky, be cornrows
on corn bread-fed fingers.
Cut the serve face flawless.
We dictate the
market masterfully,
supplying the demand for
culture will trends appropriated
on countless occasions.
Yet somehow, we innovate.
We innovate.
We innovate to no end.
I feature this
spoken word artist
that I think is really able
to put all of the themes
that the song is
about into words
and communicate that in the most
powerful poignant way possible.
His name is Orlando Watson.
And then, I'm also featuring
Andrew Renfroe, one
of my best friends, guitarist.
We went to school together.
And they're just integral to
getting the message across.
Kingdom come to make amends,
recompense for sins against
People of the sun whose peace,
whose peace, whose peace,
whose peace is still
as it used to be.
Peace ain't promise, Your Honor.
Let's be honest and
acknowledge that.
It must be now.
[APPLAUSE]